that song I Don't Want to Miss a Thing
is based on your husband can you believe
it that's some story he said that to me
and I repeated it on TV with Barbara
walers I mean what a thing to say it's
the most romantic thing I've ever heard
I know he says to you Barra I don't want
to go to sleep spoon we're spooning you
know we've done our bits whatever and
I'm about to fall asleep and he says
that to me might what do he say exactly
I don't want to fall asleep sleep
because then I'll miss you oh my god Mel
okay yes I'll marry
you don't want to close my
eyes I don't want to fall asleep cuz I
miss you baby and that's how this song
got written that's right Diane waren was
watching she told
me wrote it down it was a powerful line
right